we have to work to survive me I work
every day non-stop I would never stop
never quit some people can't handle
success I can my whole career I told me
I couldn't do this I couldn't do that
and I made sure I did what I wanted to
you and that's the key when saying is
you do what you want to do to be
successful in your way
J he gave me this this is his part to
the baby is this is me the best and then
you know you got the classic human when
you see this with change and stuff like
this all this is is us glorifying our
success I'm excited about having a son I
want him to only know joy so when
experience something else that's not joy
you'll know that's not right I want this
pure joy pure joy William joy laughter
fun and live life and let him know you
has no worries forever whatever finds
joy in your life that's living a good
night
me I'm a music mogul I'm a music
executive I'm a DJ I'm artists when
you're successful is a lot of a out
there that want to get at you when I say
day the people I don't want you to win
they are the ones that don't want me to
be in the back of the Rolls Royce having
an interview with GQ so I make sure I'll
go buy 10 Rolls Royces don't let people
tear you down they out there will try to
tear down some next
respect is a major key because I demand
my respect and I'm going to get my
respect because some people you know
they take your kindness for weakness
love is answered love is the key and
relationships from your relationship at
home with your life your girlfriend to
your people that you work with and
people that you read every single day
it's about showing love I always say
don't burn a brain you can't walk on
water on my new album that's what
everybody notices my best work ever
my fans inspire them to make this out I
got